GUFF: OK, good evening, everyone. And welcome
to tonight's Council panel on U.S.-Russia
relations on the eve of the Sochi Winter Olympics.
We have for you tonight an all-star panel
of Russia experts across the spectrum, and
let me briefly introduce them to you.
To my left is Ambassador John Beyrle. John
is the most recent -- before Mike McFaul -- U.S.
ambassador to the Russian Federation, 2008-2012,
very active in the reset under President Obama.
Dr. Angela Stent, she's the director and -- for
the Center of Eurasian, Russian and Eastern
European Studies at Georgetown.
And Ambassador and Dr. Steve Sestanovich,
whom all of you know from his role here at
the Council. I'm clearly the most under-titled
person on this panel tonight. And so with
that degree envy, let me welcome our panelists
tonight.
I also want to give a warm welcome to the
CFR members around the nation, around the
world who are plugging into us tonight through
the live meeting stream. So welcome to everyone
there.
And I would just like to mention one housekeeping
note. Our next meeting here at the Council
is with Karl Eikenberry, Jeffrey Bader, and
Michael Green on what to do about tensions
in Asia, same time, same place tomorrow, 5:30
here at the Council. I would like to mention,
also, tonight's session is on-the-record.
Let's start with the general topic. The Sochi
Olympics are coming up, and it gives us a
very time for pause to take a look at the
state of U.S.-Russian relations. Angela, your
book is just out, and so I'd like to ask you
to kick off. How would you describe today
the state of relations at this point between
the U.S. and Russia?
STENT: Thank you very much, Drew, and I'm
delighted to be here. As usual, it's complicated.
You have the trifecta of Snowden, Syria and
Sochi, and they all illustrate different things
about this complicated, as I said, partnership.
Edward Snowden, that caused real, serious
problems in U.S.-Russian relations. The White
House was very angry that he was given political
asylum in Russia. President Obama canceled
a summit with President Putin, and I think
it's one of the reasons why neither he, nor
the vice president, nor the first lady are
going to attend the opening ceremonies at
the Sochi games. So that shows a bilateral
relationship that has many problems.
But Syria, this is an area, it's a multilateral
area where we're working quite well with the
Russians. We can maybe go into the details
of how that happened. The Russians took the
initiative. It enabled us to work with them
and ward off any kind of military attack,
so both with the chemical weapons, disarmament,
and now in Geneva, we work quite well together.
And then there's Sochi, and there again in
Sochi, it's a mixed picture. We are working
with the Russians on the security problems.
We're not working as well with them as we
might like. I think both sides are wary about
sharing too much intelligence information
with each other in dealing with the terrorist
threat, but we're working with them. Our athletes
are going there. We will be competing. We'll
send a lower-level delegation, but still this
is an area where we have done things together.
And so I think it presents a picture that
has been characteristic for the last 22 years,
since the Soviet Union collapsed, which is
on some areas, we can and must work with the
Russians. We're fated to work with them on
areas like Syria, Iran, the broader Middle
East, and on other areas, particularly bilateral
areas where we criticize them for what they
do domestically and vice versa. It's very
hard to work with them.
GUFF: John, you worked on the original reset,
and maybe you can shed some light on what
were the areas on which the U.S. and Russia
found common interests and what were the areas
where you just agreed to disagree?
BEYRLE: Well, I think as Angela notes in her
book, resets, then detentes kind of come and
go in the U.S.-Soviet and U.S.-Russia relationship.
Just in my 30 years of diplomacy, I think
I can count about three or four detentes...
SESTANOVICH: I think Angela says there were
four.
BEYRLE: There were four, OK.
SESTANOVICH: There were three initiated by
a U.S. presidents, one by Putin.
STENT: Right.
BEYRLE: So I think the question is, really,
what is it that makes a reset happen? What
are the preconditions that allow Russia and
the United States or the Soviet Union and
the United States to actually find common
ground? When I arrived in Moscow as ambassador
in 2008, I found the relationship to be about
as tense and frayed as I've ever experienced
it in my career, and this was a month before
Russian forces went into Georgia.
I think mostly for economic reasons, as a
consequence of the economic boom that Russia
enjoyed between about 2003 and 2008, the Russian
elite, the Kremlin had convinced itself, really,
that it didn't need the West anymore. And
it had even kind of conceived a narrative
that the West was responsible for some of
the problems that Russia had encountered.
So by sheer chance, when I arrived, it coincided
with President Medvedev's arrival on the scene
and, I'd say, more importantly the election
of a new U.S. president, Barack Obama, which
allowed the Russians to turn the page and
to drop the litany of grievances that they'd
conceived against the Bush administration.
But the most important reason that the reset
happened was not political, but economic.
It was the economic crisis that hit Russia
in 2008-2009, worse than any other emerging
economy. The bottom dropped out of the Russian
stock markets. The ruble lost 10 percent of
its value. Russia, which had been clipping
along at 7 percent growth for 6 or 7 years
in a row, suddenly had negative 10 percent
growth.
And what that did was give ammunition to the
economic reformers in the Russian elite who
had been arguing that it was time for the
economy to actually diversify itself and become
more modern, more innovative. President Obama
wanted to be a part of that. We saw this in
the Obama administration as an opportunity,
and we were fortunate, I would say, in that
President Medvedev at that time had several
advisers who were not only convinced that
the kind of change in the Russian economy
was -- it was time for it to happen, but they
actually knew how to work the system.
And I would say the most important outcome
of that was the WTO accession by Russia. That
would not have happened if Russia hadn't found
itself in these dire economic straits. The
other two issues I'd say that probably were
the biggest successes or the best outcomes
of the reset were the START treaty, continued
the nuclear builddown by both countries, and
the Afghanistan agreement, whereby the Russians
actually agreed to help with the resupply
of American forces in Afghanistan, all things
that Putin agreed on, but all three issues
that President Medvedev and his advisers pushed
through to find a common cause with the Obama
administration.
GUFF: Steve, having mentioned these four resets,
why is it that we keep doing this dance over
and over? Why is it that the relationship
with Russia seems to be a triumph of hope
over experience?
SESTANOVICH: Well, I think the main reason
is that Russia hasn't decided how to align
itself. It is uncomfortable with the idea
of -- of integration into the West. And it
is disinclined just to think that its ordinary
disagreements with the United States are clashes
merely of national interest.
For Putin in particular, there is a kind of
civilizational dimension to his -- his estrangement
from the West, which is -- I think one of
the reasons that the relationship has taken
on the prickly quality that it has, going
beyond just personality clashes, I think for
Putin, Putin has a different conception of
how the world ought to work. He treats sovereignty
as something semi-holy. And for him, the assertion
of Russian will is part of establishing Russian
identity in the modern world.
I mean, it's a -- this is not just a set -- and
here I think we may have left this out in
the accounts which otherwise I completely
agree with that Angela and John have given
-- there is a kind of ideological dimension
to Putin's -- the way in which he's distanced
himself from the West. It's a principle. He
doesn't want to be part of the American block,
and he doesn't think that these are just ordinary
disagreements.
The biggest one is, of course, this whole
issue of how the West relates to political
change in other countries, the idea that the
West encourages reform and transformation
is for him a -- is really anathema. And that,
I think, is the deepest kind of problem that
Russia has with us.
GUFF: Is this...
STENT: Could I just add something to that?
GUFF: Yeah.
STENT: I think that the -- we and the Russians,
if you look over -- again, over the period
-- just at the 22 years, never mind going
back -- have a very different idea about what
a good and productive relationship would look
like. And for the Russians -- and that's in
my book -- it's really the idea of, particularly
since Putin came to power, of having something
which one of my Russian colleagues described
as an equal partnership of unequals. It's
for the U.S. to treat Russia as an equal,
even understanding that in many ways we aren't,
at least since the Soviet collapse, and for
us accepting, as Steve said, what Russia is
and not trying to persuade them that they
should become more like us, whereas I think
our idea of what a productive relationship
with Russia is, is working with a Russia that
more or less shares our values. And I think
that's a fundamental problem.
BEYRLE: Yeah, I would -- if I could, I would
try to boil that down to a kind of paradigm
that we identified when we were all working
on this relationship back in the late '90s
and early 2000s. It seemed to us at that time
that Russia always wanted to have a special
relationship with the United States. The specialness,
strategic partnership, detente, whatever it
was, in a way, validated the sense of self-worth
in the Kremlin, to a certain degree, at that
time.
I think that really has changed. And when
I was back in Moscow earlier last year with
all the former U.S. ambassadors and Russian
ambassadors to the United States, Foreign
Minister Ivanov -- sorry, Lavrov -- said to
us, Russia really doesn't want a special relationship
with the United States anymore. Russia wants
a normal relationship with the United States.
And I think part of the problem is our getting
used to the fact that Russia really does not
measure its sense of self-worth or place in
the world by the level of the relationship
that it has with the United States. And I
think that's underlying a lot of some of the
tensions that we feel now.
GUFF: Steve, you mentioned this unique Russian
view of itself and its place in the world.
How much of that goes back to Russia trying
to define its identity in terms of grand Russian
destiny, its -- its messianic place in the
world, from the struggles between Slavophiles
and Westerners? Is this part of a long wave
of historic cycles? Or is this just Mr. Putin's
view of the world and where Russia fits in
according to hard-headed realistic goals?
SESTANOVICH: Well, great historians have written
about this, and great Russian historians,
too, and...
GUFF: And great panelists have, Steve.
SESTANOVICH: I'm not going to say any of that
is wrong, but I think right now, we're mostly
dealing with the -- with Russia's adjustment
to the Soviet collapse, and then the sense
of vindication that they've taken from rebuilding
themselves in their economy and society as
a kind of working international player in
the past 10 years.
So we can do a lot of grand cultural interpretation
and, you know -- this is a good group for
that -- but I think the immediate issues that
-- that have dogged the relationship have
-- may have a slightly narrower character
than that.
Putin is thinking constantly about whether
or not the United States is promoting regime
change in the former Soviet Union. In the
'90s, as John says, that was something that
everybody accepted in a way. We didn't call
it regime change. We were talking about promoting
reform. Clinton administration talked about
having an alliance with reform. In just the
way that John and Angela have described, Putin
feels that was demeaning, we've gotten past
it, we don't need it, and he feels that his
own historical standing is confirmed by rejecting
it.
BEYRLE: I think it's also worth noting that
-- I mean, we talk a lot about Putin and the
Kremlin or the Russians, and we're not talking
about one thing. I mean, there are people
in Russia now in the elite with power who
really do think that Russia's fate is tied
up in closer association with the West, or
at least in a greater economic integration
with Western institutions. And they are kind
of locked in a battle with Revanchist or -- I
think Brzezinski called them imperial nostalgics
-- who always view the outside world with
some sense of suspicion or even as a hostile
force.
And clearly, we're never part of that debate
as Westerners, but we have a huge stake in
how it turns out. And the best that we can
try to do is identify the people that we see
on the right side of the debate, the debate
that takes Russia into a more integrated way
of dealing with the outside world, because
this is the 21st century. Russians make about
35 million trips abroad on average now. The
Internet is not censored in Russia.
So the idea that the imperial nostalgics build
this mythology of a Russia under siege, building
walls to keep the outside world at bay doesn't
work in this century. And I think, you know,
the tides of history are on the side of the
reformers.
SESTANOVICH: John is absolutely right about
this. There are plenty of Russians who do
still want a special relationship with the
United States...
BEYRLE: Or with Brussels.
SESTANOVICH: ... who do view their progress
according to how they integrate with the West.
There are plenty of Russians who want to be
in the E.U.
BEYRLE: That's right, some of whom have run
for president before, like Mr. Prokhorov.
SESTANOVICH: Yep.
GUFF: But I want -- at the same time, we're
talking about integration with the West, integration
with the rest of the world, but yet the major
part of government policy, the Kremlin policy
is building the Eurasian trade and economic
and political sphere of influence at -- how
realistic, Angela, do you think the goal of
Eurasian economic trade and political space
is?
STENT: I mean, it seems -- you know, five
years ago, I think we would have thought none
of this is likely. Today, I think one can
question it more. Obviously, if you look at
what's happening in Ukraine, nobody knows
where it's going, but this is clearly an instance
where, on the one hand, it looks as if Russia,
you know, at least for the time being, has
gotten the Ukrainian government to agree to
closer integration.
I mean, at the moment, you have a customs
union with Kazakhstan and Belarus. You have
Armenia that's going to join. I doubt that
Putin can create this Eurasian union, which
will be a sort of Soviet Union-lite. But I
do think that there are profound problems
of -- in really all of the post-Soviet countries,
they all suffer from the same kind of syndrome,
which are these kind of corrupt, rather opaque
governments, and where you may have popular
movements for more democracy, and the ties
that bind with Russia may be stronger than
we thought they would be.
So I don't think there will be the creation
of another Eurasian union, but I think Putin
will do all he can to make sure that a country
like Ukraine doesn't have closer association
with the European Union and that there will
be -- that this will be still a different
bloc and it will look towards Russia.
SESTANOVICH: I think one fact that just drives
home what Angela is saying is, four of the
five Central Asian countries trade more with
China than with Russia. The Ukrainians trade
as much with Europe as with Russia. The idea
that the Russians have that their economic
weight is so great that they can dictate the
terms of economic relations or political relations
with their neighbors is, I think, really out
of date. They sort of -- that had a plausibility
20 years ago that it doesn't have anymore.
GUFF: Before we go to member questions, I
want to hit on two of your other -- two of
the other S's, Snowden, Syria, Sochi. So,
Syria. Will we see real progress on the Syria
conflict? What, John, has Russia's role been?
And what do we think the outcome is going
to be?
BEYRLE: Well, I won't hazard a guess on the
outcome. I think that Russia's position on
this has been governed largely by what Steve
talked about earlier, the sense that the United
States really doesn't have the right to throw
its weight around in the world. And much of
what motivated both President Medvedev and,
I think, especially President Putin on this
was a very clear sense that Russia was going
to put a marker down that intervention, especially
armed intervention, to change a government
was something that Russia, having acquiesced
to that in the Libya case, would never again
acquiesce to.
I think if you look at what Russia has done,
everything is very explainable, very understandable
from that point of view. We've obviously found
a modus vivendi or modus labore (ph) now.
I'm delighted to see that the two sides are
at least in the same room. I'm not sure if
they're talking to each other or not, but
the fact that they're in the same room and
the fact that the U.S. and Russia can take
credit for working together on an issue that,
for the three years -- two years, at least,
that I was ambassador was the single most
divisive issue in U.S.-Russia relations is
quite a step forward.
GUFF: Angela, do you think that Putin and
Russia essentially bailed out the Obama administration
on the Syria issue?
STENT: I'll...
GUFF: And is Russia at all vindicated on this
Syria issue?
STENT: Well, I'll be a little bit more diplomatic,
and I will say that the U.S. government -- the
White House hesitated and Russia stepped in.
And basically, I mean, I think Putin is a
very smart politician. And I think he was
able to capitalize on the dithering in the
West -- and I put the West together in general
-- about, do you use force, do you not use
force?
And I think to some extent, the Russian position
from the beginning was that Assad would prevail.
They've done something to help him prevail.
And I think at the moment, it looks as if
he may, at least for some time. And I think
the other part where they may be vindicated
was also warning that a lot of the Syrian
opposition was controlled by extremist, radical,
Al Qaida-linked forces, and we now find out
-- now find out that, in fact, that's largely
true.
So I think they're -- and they want strong
secular governments in this part of the world
for their own reasons. And I think in -- in
a way, we're not that far apart on that, but
obviously we've differed on how you get there.
GUFF: Steve, on Iran, probably the largest
issue on the foreign policy level -- is this
going to also overshadow any progress on arms
control? Has arms control now taken a back
seat to Iran and denuclearizing -- potentially
denuclearizing Iran?
SESTANOVICH: I think arms control could take
a back seat to just about any issue you could
come up with in Russian-American relations,
because the Russians aren't very interested.
This administration hoped that some kind of
arms control deal, a new START II, could be
an instrument for reviving the reset. And
the Russians just made it clear they aren't
particularly interested and have rebuffed
efforts to try to, you know, come up with
that idea, rebuff suggestions by the Americans
that they take different pieces of it, try
to make it work.
Iran is a big issue for the Russians for a
lot of different reasons. They have pretty
good relations with Iran. But they also have
the extra interest that we've been talking
about off and on here, which is that a solution
is a way of preventing the use of American
force, because American force is the big no-no
of relations between Moscow and Washington
over all the postwar decades. And it is -- both
the postwar decades.
It's what the Russians most want to avoid,
because it indicates their inability to prevent
outcomes that they -- that they don't approve
of. It shows the meaninglessness of a U.N.
veto and so forth. So there's a -- there's
a real interest on the part of the Russians
to actually make this work, and I think it's
-- I mean, most American officials believe
that the Russians have played a pretty constructive
role.
BEYRLE: But it really has changed. When I
joined the foreign service in '83, went to
Moscow on my first tour, arms control was
the center of gravity in the U.S.-Soviet relationship,
no question about it. It's what everyone wanted
to do, because it's what mattered, and not
for nothing, and it still matters, because
we're both armed to the teeth, 95 percent
of the world's nuclear weapons, as we know.
The problem is that as the arms control equation
has kind of receded, as the center of gravity,
nothing's moved into its place. I think eventually
economics, trade and investment and economic
partnerships will, but it's not there yet.
The advice that I give to the young foreign
service officers I meet now is, don't study
arms control. Don't make that your specialty.
Make your specialty the economics of energy,
and you'll have full employment in the 21st
century.
GUFF: One more question before we go to members.
Russian domestic politics, the demonstrations
of a year, 18 months ago are now kind of a
distant memory, things much calmer in Moscow
and the other cities. What does that say about
the relationship between government and the
people right now in Russia? What does it say
about looking forward to the end of Putin's
first term? His second first term?
(LAUGHTER)
STENT: His second -- well, I would say -- I
mean, I'll start off, maybe. I think Putin
has quite successfully dealt with the kind
of liberal pro-Western left. I mean, in some
ways, he's made enough concessions to them,
he's in a dialogue with them, and you don't
see that many people on the streets anymore.
That part of the opposition is quieter. It's
always divided, too.
What I think he hasn't dealt well with in
the longer run is the nationalist opposition
to him, or the people who don't like the people
from the Caucasus who work in, you know, the
big cities and who are much more hard-line
and extreme. And that, I think, may come back
to haunt him, as we see with all of the things
that are happening in the North Caucasus.
But his popularity rates are up. The question
is, I -- you know, what'll make it much more
difficult for him will be what happens in
the Russian economy, what happens to oil prices?
If growth rates are at 1.4 percent for the
next few years, as they're predicted to be,
then it makes it more difficult.
GUFF: Steve?
SESTANOVICH: There's an interesting -- interesting
poll today or the past couple of days showing
that 68 percent of Russians would vote for
Putin today, but only 22 percent said they
want him to run again in 2018, and 47 percent
said they would prefer somebody else. So this
is a very common view, which actually you
probably could have gotten similar poll results
in 2012. A lot of people in the Russian elite,
people who'd benefited from Putinism, felt
this is a guy whose moment has passed and
for Russia to become a normal country, we
need to be able to draw on new leaders, we
need a system in which we actually have replacement
of leaders, where democratic processes become
a bit more meaningful.
What does it mean that all of this -- all
the protest disappeared, that -- you know,
you have had (inaudible) by the opposition
to local elections, you know? There are elections
for the Moscow City Council this year, and
if you're a serious activist in (inaudible)
that's what you're focusing on, gubernatorial
elections, as well.
But it's amazing to me how much -- we think
we do our elections early -- how many Russians
are already talking about 2018 and how much
their sense is, if only we could find some
way to edge this guy out.
GUFF: Good. We have 30 minutes of time for
member questions, so let me open up the floor
to questions. I remind you, your questions
and the entire meeting is on-the-record. Please
stand, state your name and affiliation, and
ask your question.
Sir?
QUESTION: Hi, I'm Leonid Kishkovsky of the
Orthodox Church in America and the World Conference
of Religions for Peace. And I would like to
thank the panelists for extremely lucid and
helpful commentary. Although Ukraine was mentioned,
it still is the elephant in the room, certainly
as we meet today and this week. The position
of the foreign ministry and the government
of Russia has been that they scrupulously
observe neutrality and do not interfere in
internal affairs of Ukraine and that the West
has been interfering grossly and inappropriately.
Now, the latter point may be true, but it's
been ineffective, whereas the more quiet interference
of the Russian Federation seems to have been
effective, at least at the governmental level.
I call friends in Ukraine a lot these days,
and they are convinced that the greatest influence
on decisions by the president of Ukraine comes
from the Kremlin and Moscow.
GUFF: Question is?
QUESTION: And the question is, what are you
thinking -- the panelists -- about the Ukraine-Russia
relationship, which I think has a lot of potential
impact on what happens in Europe and also
what happens between the U.S. and Russia?
BEYRLE: I think the overall problem, Father
Kishkovsky, is that there are still too many
people in power in Russia who measure Russia's
power and influence the old-fashioned way,
by how weak the neighbors are. That's not
a 21st century view. That's not a view that
says if Ukraine or the Baltics or Central
Asia is a robust trading partner, that's good
for Russia. But unfortunately, it's, for understandable
reasons, the way a lot of people still measure
Russia's strength.
I think the other problem with regard specifically
to Ukraine is there are still, unfortunately,
too many people who don't see Ukraine as a
separate sovereign entity, whose concept of
Russia, if you want to call them imperial
nostalgics, is inconceivable without Ukraine
as a part of that. Until that knot is cut,
we're, I'm afraid, going to -- probably in
for more disagreements and more tension, rather
than less.
GUFF: Esther?
QUESTION: Hi, Esther Dyson. I'd just love
to hear your comments on what Navalny published
this morning. Is that going to change those
poll results that Steve mentioned? What else
-- it's not that anybody's really surprised,
but seeing it all out in public I think has
got to have some impact.
GUFF: Can you just -- Esther, can you just
describe it for people who haven't seen it?
STENT: Is this about the Sochi Olympics?
QUESTION: Yeah, it's -- so Navalny, the opposition
leader who was in jail, let out of jail, whatever...
SESTANOVICH: Ran for Moscow mayor.
QUESTION: ... ran for Moscow mayor, much to
-- was allowed to run for Moscow mayor. That
was the surprising part. On his website today,
published in amazing detail records, documents,
data, about all the corruption and construction
and criminal enterprises and lack of completion
of all the facilities in Sochi.
STENT: I think -- I mean, I'll just start
off, maybe. I think a lot of Russians understand
that there's been a lot of corruption and
they don't believe what the government says,
anyway. And so -- and the people -- you know,
he's preaching to the choir. The people who
support him are going to be outraged by this,
but they've been outraged, anyway.
And I don't think it's going to make that
much difference. I mean, the figure -- Medvedev
used the figure $51 billion. Putin apparently
used the figure of $7 billion at some point.
Now Navalny says it's, what, $70 billion?
I don't think it'll make that much difference,
because people -- you know, still, most Russians
would like those games to succeed, because
it's going to be a very important moment.
SESTANOVICH: I'd just add one thing. Corruption
is a kind of wild card in Russian politics.
There is -- you can mobilize people with a
certain amount of outrage about this. "They're
stealing from us." And that -- that has energized
people in the past. The poll results all show
that. And Navalny is an interesting character,
because he's been able to do this kind of
in the open. You know, he asks people to send
him information.
They don't do anything -- they don't hire
private investigators. You know, they get
most -- I mean, the Navalny model for exposing
corruption is just -- is...
GUFF: Crowd-sourcing.
SESTANOVICH: ... is to invite it. It's -- you
know, right, WikiLeaks. Good analogy.
GUFF: Wikipedia.
SESTANOVICH: And he has made himself a very
formidable character in Russian politics on
this basis. They have sought to give him a
little running room when it has been convenient,
but you should not think that he's going to
be in the clear completely.
A little story about Navalny. He's registered
– has been elected as the leader of the
People's Alliance Party. The Kremlin quickly,
after he was elected leader of the People's
Alliance Party, registered another People's
Alliance Party and now won't register his,
because it's got the same name as somebody
else.
So the -- you know, they are -- they're working
on him. They're closing off these avenues.
So I wouldn't -- I just wouldn't rule out
the idea that you can mobilize people in an
angry way against...
(CROSSTALK)
GUFF: You think we're beyond it. OK.
Please?
QUESTION: Marta Varela, formerly of Hunter
College. A follow-up on Sochi. The host country
has, in many years, that they've acted as
the sponsor of the Olympics gotten a kind
of bounce from that. Now, you know, as the
former speaker said, there is a great deal
of knowledge that the Olympics have involved
a great deal of corruption. Will Putin get
some kind of Sochi bounce from this? And if
so, how long will it last? And is it going
to be something effective in terms of his
doing exactly what you spoke of, Steve, exerting
the will in a particularly Russian form on
events?
QUESTION: OK, Sochi bounce. I think everyone
needs to comment on that one.
STENT: I mean, I'll start off. So the -- I
mean, the reason Putin obviously wanted these
Olympics and he got them, in 2007 and, really,
when Russia was doing fantastically well economically
-- I mean, it was before the crash -- was
to show that not only Russia is back, but
it can build a world-class tourist resort,
it's going to excel in the games, the athletes
are going to do well.
And some of that has already become tarnished
before it happened. One of it -- one thing
has to do with the corruption and the realization
and the questioning about whether these facilities
are going to be completed and in what shape
they're going to be. Then there's, of course,
the question of the sub-tropical climate,
so one hopes they have enough snow, but maybe
they do.
And then you have to ask yourself why they
passed this legislation before the Sochi Olympics,
you know, the so-called homosexual propaganda
legislation, that's obviously caused an uproar.
It's alienated people. It's added an entire
dimension to this which they really didn't
need.
And then he's put himself forward, as we've
already heard from Steve now, that Russia
is the leader, if you like, of the new conservative
international, that it represents traditional
Christian values, which the West doesn't.
I'm not sure when the Sochi games are over
whether -- I mean, what kind of a bounce it
will give him. He would also like Sochi now
to be a sort of world-class tourist resort
that people will go to in the future, remains
to be seen.
I mean, even if there are no terrorist incidents,
which hopefully there won't be, and there
are no other, you know, incidents that have
to do with protests against Russia's laws,
I'm not sure that it will give him that bounce,
because of all the other things that have
preceded it.
BEYRLE: I think that even though Russians
do list corruption as their number-one concern
about the country when asked by pollsters,
it's the kind of corruption that makes them
have to pay $25 to get the sheets changed
at the hospital where their grandfather's
staying. Corruption on the scale of $70 billion
that Navalny maybe rightly points out I don't
think is going to really redound to Putin's
discredit.
More discrediting, I think, would be an Olympics
which is judged by the outside world as a
failure or is lampooned as, "Nice try, but
you just really didn't manage to do anything."
Putin's trump argument will be, as Angela
said, this wasn't $70 billion spent to stage
an Olympics. It was $70 billion invested in
the infrastructure of our main southern resort,
and that's as good for the Russian people,
who want to take a vacation there, as for
the Bulgarians or the Germans.
QUESTION: Sochi bounce?
SESTANOVICH: You know, pocketbook issues are
going to be more important than the Sochi
bounce. You know, we remember the '69 Mets
here, but I don't think that's what's going
to happen.
You know, you've got an economic slowdown
in Russia that is pretty disturbing to a lot
of people in the policy elite, trying to figure
out what to do about it. I think it's -- it's
the first time in a long time you had Russian
growth slower than America two years in a
row. For -- you know, Russia grew twice as
fast as in the United States in the past decade.
It's now growing more slowly.
That is a threat to Putinism in a way that
-- probably greater than, you know, the exposure
of corruption. That's what he's got to deal
with the day after Sochi. That's stuff -- he's
got a full plate of problems to deal with.
GUFF: I'm very surprised, actually, at all
the responses. The American public's view
of Russia is -- seems to be still locked in
the -- in the Cold War...
SESTANOVICH: You're calling us the American
public...
(CROSSTALK)
(LAUGHTER)
BEYRLE: Or are you contrasting?
GUFF: But no one feels that when the lights
go on, and NBC starts to show the games and
patriotism starts and medals are given out,
that this view of Russia will change and become
a little more modernized?
BEYRLE: In this country?
SESTANOVICH: Oh, you mean the outside view...
QUESTION: In this country. Yeah, in America.
STENT: In this country.
SESTANOVICH: Oh. That kind of bounce, I can't
predict. Inside Russia, you know, we should
remember that morning in America in 1984 was
connected to the '84 Olympics in Los Angeles.
There was a kind of national euphoria over
that. You can't rule that sort of thing out.
BEYRLE: Which the Soviets boycotted, if I
recall.
GUFF: OK, next question, please, with the
-- your glasses, yes, and the necklace.
QUESTION: Hi, my name's (OFF-MIKE) I'm a former
Sovietologist (OFF-MIKE)
(LAUGHTER)
BEYRLE: We're all -- we're all unemployed
ex-Sovietologists.
(CROSSTALK)
QUESTION: (OFF-MIKE) nice to see some employed
ones. My question is about civil society and
gays, really. And so Khodorkovsky let out,
Pussy Riot let out. Like, this week it's OK
to be gay in Russia. What happens post-Sochi?
Will there be any positive -- what's your
prediction for post-Sochi, both on gay rights
and also on civil society, freedom of speech,
those types of issues?
STENT: Maybe -- can I start off with that?
I -- I think that -- I mean, this legislation
that was passed, it has the backing -- the
strong backing of the Russian Orthodox Church.
It has -- it's also trying to appeal to the
Muslim population of Russia. I've heard Putin
say, you know, these are traditional Christian
values, but they're also traditional Muslim
values. Putin the other day gave an interview
on one of our talk shows saying 70 countries
in the world have similar legislation, and
7 of them behead people for this, by the way.
So I think this is part of a longer-term -- this
is how this current Kremlin has staked out
its appeal both domestically and abroad, that
this isn't part of Russian culture and you
shouldn't force it on us. And I also think
the release of Khodorkovsky and the Pussy
Riot people, I think that was largely done
to sort of preempt criticism at the Sochi
Olympics. He let them out. He let the Greenpeace
people out. It doesn't really auger any liberalization.
I would be very surprised if that was so.
SESTANOVICH: Just a word, though, about civil
society in general, because I would say that
we tend to exaggerate Putin's success in repressing
civil society groups that are involved in
all kinds of activism, environmental activism,
you name the issue. And those people have
a tougher time getting funds from abroad,
but they are still able to do it, and they've
got a lot of mission and a lot of enthusiasm
and a lot of ability to operate, really, across
Russia in the big cities and smaller ones.
I think there's a -- what I hear from Russians
is, don't count us out. We are much more resilient
than Putin thinks and able to organize and
take action in a way that he's going to be
surprised by. So I -- there's a kind of confidence
and ebullience there that I -- I think we
should not lose sight of.
GUFF: Uh-huh, question in the very back?
QUESTION: Hi, my name is Contessa Bourbon
from the New York Times. I'd like to ask,
how optimistic are you that a new reset for
U.S. and Russian relationship will take place
in the aftermath of Sochi Olympics, considering
that they are cooperating in security matters
to prevent terrorist attacks?
BEYRLE: Well, I'll try it. You said, how confident
am I that a new reset will take place in the
U.S.-Russia...
GUFF: A fifth -- a fifth reset.
BEYRLE: A fifth reset? Very confident. Because
the history of U.S.-Russia relations is a
never-ending boom-and-bust cycle, series of
boom-and-bust cycles. I just saw this week
that the International Space Station has been
nominated for the Nobel Peace Prize next year.
This is a joint Russian-American project which
will lead to, if it actually happens, if it's
granted the Nobel Peace Prize, a tremendous
outpouring of good feeling on both sides.
The Americans and Russians are working together
more in Syria than we were a year ago, as
I pointed out earlier. And I think the -- the
figures on trade and investment, especially
the American investment in Russia, the success
of American companies in Russia, also augers
well for a bit of an uptick from what I think
is probably a low point that we hit maybe
a year, 14 months ago in the relationship.
But then it'll go down again.
(LAUGHTER)
STENT: So the real answer is, it would be
much better if there were no more resets.
I mean, we've had this rollercoaster relationship
with Russia. It's much better to stand back
and say, we work on some areas very well together.
There are other areas where we don't work
that well together. And as long as the -- we
have the current sort of system that exists
in Russia and the attitudes towards each other,
we shouldn't keep trying to find some golden
key to a much better relationship, because
that then leads to disappointment. The expectations
are wrong. The relationship has to be much
more realistic.
GUFF: Yes, with the -- holding the paper?
QUESTION: Thank you. Laurie Garrett from the
Council. I think until the Boston Marathon,
the average American could not have told you
what part of the planet Dagestan was on, and
probably most Americans could not on a map
tell you where Chechnya is, and certainly
not Abkhazia or any of the heavily divisive
areas.
So they're hearing on the news about black
widows, and they hear the U.S. Olympics Committee
says don't wear anything that looks American
if you're in Sochi, and that even the athletes,
when they're not in the village or in competition,
are not to wear anything that looks American,
explain to us, why is this incredibly powerful,
almost police state, however you want to characterize
Putin's government, unable to control and
stifle these separatist movements? And how
much are Americans outside of the Boston Marathon
likely to be targeted by them?
SESTANOVICH: I was a little surprised by the
suggestion that Americans were targets. And
it may be that that is the expression of some
kind of intelligence that somebody has picked
up that some particular group or individual
has got, you know, an aim to target Americans.
But I think the purposes of the -- you know,
the Caucasus Emirate groups, the sort of -- the
terrorist groups that have been operating
in the Caucasus for some time is -- and outside,
I mean, you know, bombing in other -- bombings
in other cities, they aren't making Americans
their targets. And I would -- I'd be a little
surprised to discover that that's the nature
of the operations that they're -- that they're
conducting.
The -- you know, some people have asked whether
-- how damaging it will be for Putin to -- if
there is some kind of terrorist attack. I
think the -- it will be embarrassing, and
it will be a revelation of the limits of his
power. But his response to it will be what
it has been in almost all other cases, and
that is to extend his power, to make the case
that this sort of attack requires a concentration
of power in his hands, and a strengthening
of the state, and an ability to act against
its enemies. So that -- and there's just no
doubt about that. That will be -- that will
be the opportunity, as he sees it, if there's
an attack.
GUFF: Left side, please?
QUESTION: Thanks. I'm Kimberly Marten from
Barnard College at Columbia University. I'm
wondering if each of you could say a little
bit more about the Russian relationship with
China. Steve talked about Chinese energy investments
or investments in general in Central Asia.
It had looked a few years ago like there might
be Russia-Chinese competition in Central Asia,
but it appears more recently as though Russia
is almost falling in line behind China.
So what do we think the Russia-China relationship
will look like in, let's say, a decade?
BEYRLE: Well, I think the -- from the Russian
point of view, the China relationship is arguably
the most important one that they have to manage,
maybe in this century, certainly for the next
10 to 20 years, and it stems from that imbalance,
demographic and economic imbalance that you
see on the border between Siberian Russia
far east and the parts of China that are pushed
up against, where you've got 220 million Chinese
and only about 8 million Russians. I mean,
they're mirror images of each other. The Russian
land is bereft of people and full of resources,
and the Chinese land just across the border
is exactly the opposite, no resources and
nothing but people.
Managing that is the biggest single challenge
that, when I meet with thoughtful Russians,
they identify after they get done talking
about the E.U. and NATO enlargement. They
start talking about that. And the idea that
somehow Russia and China are fated to be allies
somehow against us or against the Europeans,
if you -- as you pointed out, if you look
at the parts of the world that matter most
to both countries, they're rivals, China and
Russia. Central Asia, if Russia is falling
in line behind China, that's going to rile
a lot of people in Russia, because they still
see part of Central Asia as their backyard.
Meanwhile, the Russians in places like Vietnam
are helping the Vietnamese develop their offshore
energy resources in waters that the Chinese
say are theirs. So I think we all have a lot
of work to do to make sure that the rise of
China's managed in a way that keeps China
playing by international rules, but Russia
in particular has to manage that relationship
carefully, and right now the only way it can
do it is politically.
STENT: Yeah, I was in China a couple of years
ago talking to Chinese Russia experts about
all of this. And the Chinese are very clear-eyed
about everything. They say, Russia supports
us on all the important foreign policy issues
for us, Taiwan, Tibet, a multipolar world.
We can work together.
Then you start talking to them about the domestic
system in Russia, how Russia is governed or
not governed, and they were pretty critical.
If -- I mean, the Chinese see this very much
as -- you know, to quote a colleague of mine,
an access of convenience. It's very useful
for them. It's instrumental for them. They
need the Russian energy. They work with Russia.
Again, they support each other in the United
Nations Security Council, but there's no kind
of romantic notion of a great strategic partnership.
I think on the Russian side, it's very complicated,
because, on the one hand, they also see this
as an important partnership with China, again,
against, you know, the Western -- if you read
their foreign policy doctrines, you know,
the number-one enemy is still NATO and the
United States. And you can't even talk about
China publicly in Russia in that vein.
But on the other hand, as John said, I mean,
you go to the Russian far east, and it's quite
clear what the dynamics are there. And in
the long run, the Russians have to be very
concerned about this, and I don't think they
know how to manage that, either.
SESTANOVICH: Just one word on this. For the
Russians that -- you know, China is a fabulous
market and opportunity to develop a relationship
that pays off economically. The problem is
letting themselves be in the position where
they don't have any other friends. And that's
not a good relationship to have with the Chinese.
And they are working a little bit at some
of the networking that they need to do in
order to make sure that they are not all by
themselves against the Chinese. So you see
some cultivation of the Japanese. They've
really worked at getting Prime Minister Abe
to come to the games. There is an awareness
that being -- being all by yourself in the
-- in a junior partner relationship with the
Chinese may not be so great.
GUFF: Yes, please, front row?
QUESTION: Bill Drozdiak, American Council
on Germany. Do you think there's a conscious
and deliberate strategy on the part of Putin
to use the Snowden revelations to damage and
drive a wedge between the United States and
the European allies? Or is it just opportunism
that he's taking advantage of?
And, secondly, just -- would it be in American
interests to export a lot of the shale oil
gas we're producing in order to drive down
the price and put pressure on Putin?
BEYRLE: Let me try...
STENT: I'll take -- oh, sorry.
BEYRLE: OK. You want Snowden?
STENT: Can I start with Snowden?
GUFF: Start with Snowden, and then, John,
please jump in.
STENT: I mean, in -- in the old days of the
Cold War, right, we'd all talk about the Soviet
Union is trying to drive wedges between, you
know, the United States and its European allies.
I mean, I haven't -- I can't remember a time
when U.S.-German relations -- I mean, they
haven't been this fraught for a very long
time, and this is all thanks to Edward Snowden.
So if Putin had dreamed something up, I think
he couldn't have dreamed something better,
in terms of everyone shocked, we know there's
a lot of hypocrisy in all of this, but at
least outwardly everyone has to be shocked
that these things are happening.
And, you know, one can debate how deliberate
this was, but it certainly worked out pretty
well on that score, in terms of, you know,
the problems between the U.S., particularly,
and Germany now, and this is not going away.
And you may have -- I'm sure you followed
his latest interview yesterday on -- with
Hubert Seipel, I think, where, you know -- and
he reveals more and more about all the terrible
things we're doing to Germany. So this -- you
know, it's almost a fantasy, I would think,
for someone in the Kremlin.
BEYRLE: I agree that this is mostly opportunism
on Putin's part, and I think it's mostly run
its course. Snowden now is a wasting asset,
if he ever was an asset for the Russians.
The benefit that Putin got from sheltering
Snowden and, in essence, sticking a finger
in the American eye will pay negative dividends
in greater measure in the months to come,
and that's why I don't think after the one-year
temporary asylum that Snowden was granted
by Putin that this will be extended, and you
can even see this a bit in some of the things
that both Putin and Snowden are beginning
to say.
STENT: But not Pushkov, huh? He said he can
stay there as long as he likes.
BEYRLE: Not running the country, last I checked.
GUFF: Yes, please?
QUESTION: Norma Globeman (ph), ex-UNDP. President
Obama has three years almost left to go, two
years of which will be lame-duckism, but never
mind. What is your view of the state of the
relationship with Putin now, the real state
of the relationship, and to what degree will
it be a potentially useful or an impediment
-- how serious an impediment, if it is an
impediment, over the next few years?
GUFF: Well, this is probably good questions
to close on. We're approaching the witching
hour of 7 o'clock, so let's -- why don't we
wrap up with some closing thoughts on that
topic?
SESTANOVICH: Bill Clinton, when he went to
Moscow in 2000 and Putin has just become president,
said that his feeling about Putin was that
he was like somebody looking over the shoulder
of the person he's talking to at a cocktail
party and looking for somebody more interesting
who's coming in. And before too long, Putin
is going to be doing that to Barack Obama.
Barack Obama doesn't seem to like it very
much. And I would say, if there's been a downgrading
of the relationship on the U.S. side, probably
been as much the president's doing as anybody
else.
You're right that lame-duckism is a -- is
a problem for American presidents. It hasn't
kept American presidents from reaching major
agreements with Russian presidents in their
last year or two in office. But I'm not sure
that either side really has an agenda that
will yield that kind of agreement. They're
not into reset-ism. This is more -- has become
a more transactional relationship.
STENT: I think, you know, in the beginning,
President Obama, this was a very high priority
for him. We had the reset. Then, when Putin
and Medvedev switched jobs, it got much more
difficult. I personally -- I agree with Steve
-- I don't think this a high priority for
the White House. I don't think there's much
on the bilateral agenda for the next few years.
The economic relationship we will try and
push, and we're trying to do that. They're
not interested in any more arms control. So
I think you're going to see generally Russia
taking a lower -- it already has priority,
except in those areas, international, multilateral
ones, where we will work together. But bilaterally,
I think not much.
BEYRLE: I think there's always a tendency
to overanalyze the body language between leaders.
I mean, having sat in meetings with Bill Clinton
and Boris Yeltsin, I can tell you, the body
language in that -- some of those meetings
wasn't very good, either.
GUFF: But it sells books.
BEYRLE: But it depends on which picture you
choose. In the end, both leaders are very
pragmatic. Putin has showed that pragmatism
again. He showed it at the end of the Bush
administration, the Bush 43 administration,
and I think, at the end of the day, this is
an important relationship for both countries.
It has to be, simply because of the special
place that we both occupy.
And we really -- and I think both leaders
realize this -- don't have the luxury to downgrade
the relationship to the degree that I think
the press sometimes accuses us of having done.
GUFF: Well, a big thank you to our panelists
tonight. I want to make one reminder.
(APPLAUSE)
Yeah, one very important reminder. Angela
Stent's book is available for sale right outside
our doors here and available on Amazon.com.
Steve Sestanovich's book comes out in preview
on Amazon.com, called "Maximalist." Please
take a look at it. Thank you very much.
BEYRLE: And I'm still writing.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)